he wanted to understand how did
Guttenberg go about making those first
books and understand it he had to do it
please welcome out massive decree so I'm
here to talk about the mass production
of data and like you said this comes
about from some explorations and
experiments have been doing over the
last year so first of all who am I like
I said I'm Matthew dockery I'm an
industrial artist from Seattle and
metrology I do public art installations
kinetic and fire sculptured Burning Man
and occasionally I do recreations of
historical artifacts when I have the
time and that's how this came about last
year I started to get into printing like
old-school letterpress printing and I
really enjoyed it I took some classes
and it really got me wondering where the
technology came from and how it
developed and so of course the first
thing you think of when you ask that
question is Johannes Gutenberg and
probably everyone in this room knows
better than to say he invented printing
because he didn't it had been around for
a long time before him but he also
didn't invent movable type he didn't
even invent metal Movable Type both of
those had been around in China and Korea
for quite some time before him so given
that why do we still know his name why
do we talk about him and why do we
perceive quite rightly that he changed
the world in fundamental ways so to
understand that you have to understand
something about printing which is that
to print something you need a lot of
type a lot of individual slugs of type
this type case is pretty representative
there are hundreds and hundreds of
pieces there to kind of drive this home
I took a page from Plutarch more or less
at random and broke it out and there are
almost 3,000 individual characters on
that one page not counting spaces
including 419 lowercase es alone so if
you want to print you need a lot of type
and it needs to be pretty consistent the
tolerances are actually pretty tight for
a 15th century process so how did
Gutenberg do it well we don't know the
first documentation comes from about a
hundred years after his lifetime and as
you can see it's not very good this is
literally it and it doesn't even make a
lot of sense when you look at it up
close
um by the time in the Enlightenment we
start to get some technical
documentation of quality and at that
point it matches the historical
artifacts we do still have remaining so
we can say at that point pretty
confidently how it was done so this is a
hand mold which is exactly what it
sounds like it's a mold you hold in your
hand you pour the lead in at the top it
flows into a letter form at the bottom
you open it up a saga type comes out and
you'll repeat that process hundreds of
times so now that raises the question of
course is where is that letter format
the bottom come down and it's called a
matrix um this is actually the set of
matrices that we get the modern typeface
Garamond from and you need one matrix
for every letter for every size upper
case lower case you need a lot of them
so now how do we make a lot of matrices
will you use something called punches
which is just a hardened steel punch in
the shape of the letter you want and you
stamp that into the soft copper and you
have your matrix and you can speed up
the production of punches a little bit
by using something called counter
punches which are just punches which
form the negative space inside letters
and those can be reused to some degree
but for the most part it comes down to
carving these carving and engraving
these punches so I wanted to understand
that because I you know I like I'm a
metal guy like to get my hands on things
so I tried doing it this is the negative
space inside a capital letter D um it's
not super hard but it is fiddly and it
takes a lot of time um it would take
upwards of a year to make one set of
matrices and I don't have that time so I
did what anyone in the 21st century does
I designed it in CAD and got it 3d
printed I'm first in plastic then in
metal and with that I could actually
start to do some type casting and see
how it works so we made some type metal
using a classic recipe I'm melted up and
started pouring it in and the results
were well they were okay turns out
there's this cool jerk technique that
people who really know what they were
doing would do to force the molten type
metal down into the letter form but I'll
aoi for that I think the results came
out pretty interesting and it it let me
to think about some things about this
which I hadn't really seen in that light
before but data is always physical and
it's easy to forget that now
but your data your bits they're stored
in Adam somewhere even if it's on the
other side of the planet and that means
that implies a technological process in
an industrial process to support that
volume you know following from that if
you want to change the world like
Gutenberg did you need mass production a
printing trust by itself doesn't change
the world unless you can actually take
your invention to billions of people
it's just a novelty and that's why I
think we still know who Gutenberg is so
thank you very much I have the hand
molded some type if you want to find me
afterwards and if we can find a corner
maybe we'll actually do some casting so
thank you
you